ma ok ciao ragazzi ecco a voi le 40 cose
su cui le ragazze mettono più spesso
attenzione sto generalizzando è quindi
anch'io mi sto tirando fuori da tante
bugie che non dico per esempio mamma è
vero sono stata solo un ragazzo la
merita ma torniamo a noi iniziamo
non ho mai detto è per di tutto lo dico
inizio domani non sono grata alla fine
se non mi risponde di che mi incazzo
di solito risponde che sto stronzo no
non sono incazzata
io non mai fatto uno screenshot di
conversazione lo trovo veramente
patetico di guardare il tuo numero
sono fidanzata mi spiace non mi sono mai
modificato una foto o per usura
no io non lo guardo uomini e donne zio
canonico resto lasciati no non vado in
palestra sono così ti costituzione
amo sono in macchina cinque minuti
arrivo ma draghi che carina non dovevi
ci mancava solo che si presentasse
all'epoca votare carlos affrontano no io
mi arrabbio se guarda le altre
lo so che sono care però vi servivano
troppo linea kids che non servono delle
decolletè giallo canarino scusa io adoro
essere single dai lavori di verità kg
incazzo da aie
eh si io sono unica singolo del gruppo
ma giuro che non mi pesa che sono
guardano l'un per cento e batteria si
spegne il telefono sull motivo no no
grazie non ho fame navajo mia rabbia di
casa mette laica da altri figurati
con touring non so cosa sia queste parte
noi ragazzi al primo appuntamento non
facevano niente neanche un bacio se
siamo scusa se non ci risposto prima sia
stata veramente impegnatissima non te lo
giuro non ho niente di troppo in
formissima ingrassata ma dove molti
prima grinta io non uso il push up
questa è tutta roba mia
noi lo guardo più sul set anche perché
se il talk arrestato solo l'inter è al
solito il bastardo ti piacciono le
unghie sì certo sono naturali sono mie
io in palestra ci vado tutti i giorni no
io non sono assolutamente pettegola in
ficcanaso
non va bene ma non è capito marcucci
resto miss insieme peccato giulia sempre
un po più come sa fare una città che
punto si questi riflessi sono naturali
si sono chiariti previsto né io no io
sono gelosa
se notate ha detto solo con un ragazzino
scusa che sono stancati di sì ma critica
anche tipo di l'ultima bene ciao ciao
dopo contaci non sono vita truccata e o
solo pò di pescara se vi scrive è sicuro
non gli rispondo come ti ho scritto così
sfondo cantate vita bellissima silvia
tantissimi amiche ma non mi dà fastidio
un elastico no non ce l'ho mi dispiace
vai serve a me fai un calo minore che ha
capelli assolutamente no non ho le
station sono naturali mar i capelli
io ero un letto stupido vi è piaciuto
ricordatevi di iscrivervi al canale e
fatemi sapere commentando qui sotto qual
è la bugia che ripete più spesso e
ricordarvi di seguirmi su snapshots
instagram facebook e visigalli no vabbè
amore ciao
[Musica]